todos ustedes tienen algo en común
conmigo tuvieron una infancia
en el caso de la mía fue una infancia
feliz a pesar de muchas cosas malas que
ocurrieron afuera de mi casa
pero fue feliz primero porque tuve unos
padres maravillosos
que llenaron mi habitación de libros y
esos libros literalmente me llevaron a
otros mundos a otras épocas
fue gracias a la lectura de autores como
julio verne o francisco coloane que me
enteré de la existencia de esta tierra
dura fría
y bellísimas tan lejana pero a la vez
tan cercana a nosotros los magallánicos
estoy hablando de la antártica
pero también
y otros factores de los cuales me di
cuenta después que me gatillaron un
interés inusitado por visitar algún día
este lugar resulta que tengo
antecedentes familiares están tanteos
un primo de mi padre fue su oficial del
ejército de chile estuvo sirviendo
durante dos temporadas como encargado de
motores y de los generadores que
mantenían con vida a la base bernardo
o'higgins y él se llamaba exactamente
igual que yo rafael cheuquelaf
les voy a contar una anécdota de la cual
él es protagonista que grafica los
obstáculos y prejuicios que él tuvo que
superar en el chile de los años 70 para
llegar a servir en esa base un
privilegio
llegó un día un comandante nuevo a la
base
y él ya estaba trabajando y siente
pasado
en un momento de camaradería sin
formalmente la pregunta oiga usted y
cuál es su nombre completo quién le dice
yo me llamo rafael cheuquelaf catrileo
y el comandante como medio extrañado por
esta asociación de nombres indígenas
le dice pero usted como sabe todas estas
cosas sabes de tecnología de motores y
bueno él le dijo le respondió con
picardía pero con mucha educación lo que
pasa es que los mapuches somos casi
humanos mi comandante
i
se lo tomó bien en toda clase de juego
que he hecho y todo lo que he hecho
y él siguió trabajando de hecho en el
comando antártico del ejército estuvo a
cargo durante varios años del
abastecimiento de la base compraba
víveres en puntarenas llenaba los buques
y los mandaba la antártida
lamentablemente él falleció muy joven y
no pude conocerlo en persona yo era un
bebé prácticamente
y su propio pregunto que conversaciones
interesantes podría haber tenido con él
el segundo choque en llegar a la
antártica es mi señor padre
rubens en clase que fue el primer
funcionario del mineduc en supervisar
personalmente la escuela de villa las
estrellas fue dos veces
y bueno el tercer choque en irá ya está
parado aquí ante ustedes soy yo
como lo hice yo yo no soy científico no
soy funcionario ni de las fuerzas
armadas ni de ninguna repartición del
gobierno
y tampoco tengo el dinero para ir como
turista bueno lo hice principalmente
como músico
resulta ser
cuando uno tiene sueños que sobrepasan
las posibilidades reales es sumamente
importante creo yo tener a un socio que
luche contigo lado a lado para poder
concretar ese sueño yo tengo la suerte
de tener un socio de esa naturaleza que
se llama héctor águila triviño
él hace ya 22 años me invitó a hacer
música con él en un proyecto
experimental electrónico populista
pero en su casa
se llama lluvia hacia el proyecto y con
ese proyecto hasta el día de hoy hemos
grabado discos hemos hecho nuestros
propios documentales
tocados en magallanes tocado en chile y
en el extranjero
y cuando estábamos como a la mitad de
nuestra carrera allá por hace unos 12
años atrás
conversando como solemos hacerlo cuando
queremos emprender una nueva aventura
creativa llegamos al tema de la
antártica y resulta de que él había
leído los mismos libros que yo había
visto en los mismos documentales que yo
y dijimos ya hagámoslo en nuestra
ingenuidad pensamos vamos a hacer un
disco sobre la historia de la antártica
y vamos a viajar a la antártica a
tocarlo
los jaivas viajaron no se pudieron ir
porque nosotros no
gracias al auspicio del instituto
antártico chileno publicamos el disco lo
presentamos en el primer concierto de
música que se ha hecho de esto en la
sede del inac
y aquí comenzó la otra aventura y la
antártica
y ahí nuestra ingenuidad quedó revela
ante nosotros nos dimos cuenta que no
era fácil y
una parte siempre cuando aborda temas
que les son desconocidas desde la
ignorancia más absoluta entonces tuvimos
que aprender de que ir a la antártica no
es fácil por temas logísticos por temas
de costos y porque mucha gente quiere
mucha gente quiere ir a la antártica
y no siempre con propósitos muy claros
o muy al turista hay gente que
simplemente quiere satisfacer la
curiosidad personal sin hacer ningún
aporte al resto y volver con un trofeo
con una foto
y bueno nosotros no éramos los jaivas
tampoco no éramos gente muy conocida
entonces lo primero fue darle valor a
nuestra idea tocamos tocamos tocamos
todo lo que pudimos de esa música aquí
en puntarenas también en santiago
y bueno a todo el mundo lo explicamos
por qué música electrónica bueno porque
en la antártica no hay una cultura
originaria todo viene de afuera
hay solamente dos cosas dos cosas que
son esenciales para que el hombre
sobreviva en ese lugar la cooperación y
la tecnología por lo que nos pareció de
que la música electrónica era el
lenguaje natural con el cual podíamos
expresar esa idea
esto se resolvió hacia el final
por una parte de la fuerza aérea me
pregunto me dijo ok
nosotros podemos recibir pero tienen a
alguien que los lleve
sí
y por otro lado una empresa aérea
regional me preguntó
y nosotros podemos llegar pero tienen
alguien que los reciba sí sí sí sí
entonces las piezas se juntan
y una luminosa mañana de marzo de 2007
emprendimos rumbo a isla rey jorge
aterrizamos
y mientras los turistas hacían su
recorrido nosotros aprovechamos ese
instante con una precisión muy pensada y
muy ensayada
y tocamos en el gimnasio de la base ante
unas 40 personas ante la dotación
chilena de la base eduardo frei montalva
personal de la fach
pueden ver ahí al fondo a personal de la
base coreana
y un par de uruguayos que andan de
visita fue un recital muy bonito sobre
todo por la respuesta que tuvo y
nosotros nos fuimos a tocarles a ellos
canciones de amor ni nada ajeno su
experiencia nosotros llevábamos música e
imágenes relativas al lugar donde ellos
trabajaba así que ellos se sintieron de
alguna manera homenajeados
esa fue la misión que nosotros nos
propusimos cumplir y en solamente
4 a 5 horas de estadía en la raíz porque
la cumplimos y volvimos muy satisfechos
muy felices no solamente porque habíamos
concretado el primer concierto de música
electrónica del cual se tenga registro
en territorio antártico sino porque
había un cumplido un sueño personal que
nosotros teníamos no lo habíamos soltado
y lo logramos
pasó el tiempo
seguimos haciendo música publicamos
otros discos abordamos otros temas
conocimos otras personas también en lo
personal enfrentamos dificultades yo
personalmente me convertí en padres
circunstancias muy difíciles
y mi hija hace unos años estuvo al borde
de la muerte durante casi un año
y en esos momentos oscuros
hacía lo que hace muchas personas en esa
situación acudirán a sus mejores
recuerdos se refugiaban en ellos
entonces yo hay en horas de espera
interminables en el hospital
recordaba esa maravillosa tarde que
había vivido años antes de venir la rey
jorge
debo confesar de que sentí envidia de
personas que yo conocía y que sabía que
en ese momento estaban en la antártica
disfrutando conociendo mientras yo
estaba en santiago muerto de calor
sumido en una situación terrible llegué
a pensar de que mi hija iba a fallecer
de que yo me iba a derrumbar y que nunca
más diga hacer algo como esto
pero saben qué
ella sobrevivió a un montón de cirugías
se puso de pie
me levanto a mí
y yo volví a la antártida
no una vez sino 300
como comienza que éste aceptó hace unos
años atrás el instituto antártico
chileno encontró en sus bodegas el
registro fílmico original de las
primeras expediciones chilenas en
cantantes
que se vea y se ve a chilenos
construyendo las primeras bases en el
territorio antártico
y ahí no solamente iban marinos los
científicos también iban artistas como
francisco coloane o fotógrafos como
robert iger sonando high street
entonces nos dimos cuenta
nosotros tenemos que hacer nuestra
propia expedición tenemos que volver
tenemos que hacer el ejercicio inverso
que habíamos hecho con ese primer disco
que fue hecho desde la biblioteca de
alguna manera tenemos que crear una
nueva obra pero que esta vez sea fruto
de una expedición de una experiencia
envío en terreno
así que lo hicimos
fui invitado por inac a integrar la
expedición científica escolar
acompañando un querido en salud
aproveche ese momento d
trabajar empezar a trabajar en una idea
que teníamos que era filmar una película
nuestra sobre la vida natural y humana
en isla rey jorge y luego nosotros
ponerle la música así que estuvimos
filmando ahí y no es cierto
paisajes fauna personas y posteriormente
pudimos volver con héctor pero esta vez
a grabar sonido muchos creerán de que la
antártica es un lugar silencioso la
verdad es que dista mucho de serlo
porque a pesar de que no tiene ciudades
no tiene vehículos ni grandes
concentraciones de gente es un
continente dinámico no es un monolito de
hielo y el hielo está constantemente
cambiando de forma de tamaño
el mar la fauna y eso entremezclen no
con el sonido que hace el hombre con su
presencia en las bases eso fue lo que
fuimos a grabar que más grabar tanto
sonido como como se ve en la fotografía
emisiones electromagnéticas porque ahí
la comunicación radial es muy muy
intensa y eso lo transformamos también a
sonido y lo integramos a nuestra música
yo quisiera compartir uno de esos
pequeños registros de audio
les invito a cerrar los ojos e imaginar
por un instante que están parados en
medio de la base eduardo frei en una
noche de niebla
[Música]
sé que están oyendo ahí atrás
es un generador que está prendido día y
noche que da vida a todas las
instalaciones que están alrededor
si eso se apaga es una emergencia suena
una alarma
y el sonido más agudo que se escuchaba
lo cierto encima es una golondrina
antártica que tiene sonidos en los
farallones rocosos que estás rodeando la
base no se fijan eso era lo que nosotros
queríamos captar la mezcla entre la
naturaleza y el hombre en un sonido
y finalmente terminamos esta obra lo
presentamos con ocasión del aniversario
número 50 del instituto antártico
chileno
nosotros actualmente seguimos ligados a
esta temática antártica de hecho dentro
de un mes más vamos a presentar una
nueva obra sobre el tema pero estaba
enfocada a la ciencia en este mismo
escenario
el año pasado realizamos una gira sobre
homenajeando los 100 años del rescate de
la expedición de shackleton por parte
del piloto pardo
y yo simplemente quisiera compartir las
reflexiones y las lecciones que me dejó
esta experiencia en lo personal
primero que nada
hay que confiar en el talento propio
no podemos dejar que el potencial que
nosotros tenemos para perseguir algo
muera no podemos dejar que el
escepticismo de otros te marchiten
lo segundo no hay que ver a las
instituciones como obstáculos o como
reductos cerrados si tú te aproximas
correctamente a ellas con paciencia se
pueden convertir en tus aliadas más
valiosas de hecho nosotros esos dos que
estamos ahí somos un caso afortunado de
colaboración entre artistas e
instituciones del estado y privados
sin esa colaboración no hubiera sido
posible las obras de las cuales yo les
estoy hablando
puede parecer de que el arte no tiene
nada que ver con la antártica yo estoy
en absoluto desacuerdo con eso
si vamos atrás en el tiempo nos vamos a
dar cuenta de que los artistas han sido
fundamentales a la hora de difundir
estas temáticas les hablé de las
primeras expediciones chilenas en la
antártica
los chilenos conocieron esos viajes
épicos gracias a los artistas que
llevaban abortos
porque una cosa es descubrir algo
comprenderla pero otra cosa es hacer que
al resto del mundo le importe ese es el
rol de los artistas hacer de que la
antártica sea de importancia para todos
muchas gracias por su atención
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero es verdad